welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of marvel's
what if episode 7 what if thor were an
only child and rex midgard and dances on
ashes and steals zemo's moves without
inviting him this whole party episode
was packed with cameos and references to
the marvel films so i'm gonna break it
down frame by frame for everything you
might have missed so we opened in the
new mexico desert the same opening shot
of the first thor film interesting how
we don't see the watcher in the stars
here many other episodes opening shots
of the sky embed uwatu among the stars
but not here for as we will see this
supposedly omnipresent watcher does have
some blind spots jane foster's computer
shows the same van allen radiation belts
around the globe that eric celvig's
computer showed in the movie selvig is
not with them here though so this must
be a different outing one thankfully
without kenneth branagh's random tilted
angles natalie portman returns as jane
along with everyone aside from brie
larson the warriors three actors and
rene russo as friga but like the doctor
strange episode which i believe was a
prelude to multiverse of madness this
cast could have been lured into this
episode as a prelude to thor love and
thunder jane reports i need to talk to
the director of shield because if my
data is correct i believe an alien
invasion is imminent and two years ago
the same anomaly struck star alfa icarus
and the entire star dimmed and then poof
disintegrated jane already knows what
shield is here and she jumps to the
conclusion of it being an alien invasion
but back in the thor film she had never
heard of shield cause foster i'm agent
coulson with shields is that supposed to
mean something to me shield whatever
they are so this version of jane might
have discovered previous evidence of
extraterrestrial light that got her on
shield's radar sooner she mentions the
star alpha icarus explosion that was two
years prior which we later learned was
one of thor's past ragers alpha star now
that was an excellent party did you
really destroy that planet no no it was
more of a meteor anyway not a planet and
it was burning apart so we just kind of
helped it along and so no one got hurt
no of course not even the baby goat gary
got home safely
eventually icarus was the figure from
greek mythology who flew too close to
the sun so that his waxed wings melted
and he burned and died in the ocean
similar to the alpha star icarus burning
meteor that thor laughs off here but
thor in a way faces his own icarus-like
hubris trying to coast above it all but
comes crashing down to reality in the
closing moments we never get a firm
answer as to what exactly went down on
alpha star or what thor meant by that
goat getting to safety eventually but
maybe serta helped them burn it faster
and the whole experience is actually
super traumatic for all of its people
and its goats
their star chart shows constellations
including ursa minor which was mentioned
by jane in the film as being missing
signaling an astronomical realignment
that linked earth with asgard look what
do you see stars yeah but not our stars
see this is the star alignment for our
quadrant this time of year and unless
ursa minor decided to take a day off
these are someone else's constellations
but here ursa minor is visible meaning
thor's arrival wasn't the result of
odin's banishment but thor's chosen
party destination while odin was in
odin's sleep the bifrost overshoots them
they're here
we're too late darcy of course
referencing caroline's creepy line and
poltergeist
[Music]
they land on the vegas strip in front of
a casino that looks like the bellagio
but the bellagio isn't beside the luxor
and the excalibur like this casino is
here and that's because all these
casinos were slightly altered visually
because there's a copyright law that
requires a license fee to recreate these
landmarks and animation the bifrost hits
in front of an elvis impersonator
this same elvis later marries darcy and
howard the duck and even later there is
a skrull elvis meaning this elvis might
have been one of those earthbound
skrulls the whole time a reminder that
many among our society are scrolls we
got a secret invasion baby there's also
a guy with a pineapple shirt which might
be a nod to take awaytiti's pineapple
romper at comic con 2017 they kick off
the party as uatu observes more than
battles won or lost it's relationships
that truly define a hero the people who
shaped them their stories as he looks
down at the city all those lit streets
makes it look like for a second he's
watching them through a broken pane of
glass reminiscent of the barrier that he
moved to the other side of when he
didn't help strange supreme and he turns
away from all of this toward the stars
but missing what's going on down below
just another example of how he doesn't
always have his eye on the ball then a
slideshow shows thor and loki's
relationship including young loki
playing a trick on thor using the casket
of ancient winters to freeze him odin
holding baby loki as he does in the film
except instead of crying this cute baby
loki smiles this maybe being the true
nexus point because odin would realize
that this child doesn't need his
asgardian warmth it's also interesting
how loki later shows up as a frost giant
when he was supposed to be the runt of
his family so essentially this loki
variant was born as a truer sturdier
frost giant also notice here how they
already cover odin's eye with an eye
patch whereas in the movie it had just
been ripped out in the battle freaking
lulls odin into odin's sleep with a
singing choir of her fellow witches like
the choir who accompanied loki's play in
ragnarok but it's interesting here
they're clearly just trying to make them
fall asleep faster so they can have some
wine time also thor sits bedside totally
uninterested which is exactly where loki
was sitting in the film because thor is
kind of the jerk of this story in odin's
vault they passed the infinity gauntlet
reminding us of how in the first thor
film there was that prop infinity
gauntlet added to the background with
all six stones already in it but they
were in a different arrangement later
marvel of course retconned that gauntlet
as fake but that was a right-handed
gauntlet this one is the same
left-handed gauntlet with the correct
stone placement that thanos symbol is an
infinity war now yes the blue space
stone should still be inside the
tesseract at this point in the timeline
the reality stone should still be hidden
with the ether the gauntlet itself
wasn't forged by etri until years later
etc etc but i think the idea is that
marvel put a new fake gauntlet in the
vault the way that what if has retconned
a lot of phase one appearances of people
like rhodey and bruce banner they're
also retconning the appearance of that
phase one fake infinity gauntlet thor
drains and smashes the mug just as he
does at the diner in the thor film
volstag parties with a couple familiar
faces including a ravager and a woman
with this elaborate face paint and hair
we actually saw this kind of design on
various partiers on sakhar and ragnarok
there's this hooded masked figure we saw
people like this milling around sakhar
and ragnarok we also see several scrolls
in yondu and a member of the sovereign
from guardians volume 2. thor hugs
scourge from ragnarok thunderheart
yeah have a drink it never runs out you
try to drink it all but you can't
because it's magic he's recalling doctor
strange's magically refilling beer in
ragnarok the ships that beamed down are
mostly ones that we've seen in the
collector's vault in episode two but
were originally seen in the grand
masters garage in ragnarok including
that one with a circular window with
wings that fold up and then the simple
cube-shaped one there's also a few
asgardian viking boats that we saw as
part of loki's fleet in episode three
and some cree warships like the dark
aster thor uses scrolls to exhibit his
narcissism and as jane notices them he
does that sexy hair toss that he did in
episode three darcy expected there to be
lasers and flying cows maybe referencing
the destroy all humans game series and
then the references just keep coming i
expected him to look more like like what
e.t and less like a hottie mcscotty
beach buddy ken old school abercrombie
catalog of course referencing e.t and
scotty from star trek they use first
contact as a euphemism referencing the
1996 star trek film you can make first
contact with i don't know that guy he
looks like a loser
big talk coming from a brunette power
the duck was actually talking to a
blonde when we saw him partying on
catraxia in guardians volume 2. thor
whip hands over to the grand master at
topaz from ragnarok topaz what do i
always say i love cake i love how tobaz
is eating a whole slice of cake with her
hand and she's carrying that staff that
she and the grandmaster used to melt his
cousin carlo jane only knows thor by his
connection to norse mythology as in thor
the norse god of thunder i don't know
anything about horse gods but i don't
know how to bring the thunder actually
one of thor's successors is the god of
thunder is beta ray bill a corbinite
with a hoarse face as jane asks thor
about icarus i'd love this drunk
off-screen height man in this episode
anomaly that preceded it happened
too much tonight or too little hey
thunderboy there's more great off-screen
drunkenness when thor reminds fandral of
waking up next to a baby goat i named
him gary
yeah you did the party rages on with the
grandmaster djing just like we saw him
do in ragnarok now the music we hear is
actually a remixed version of the
grandmaster's birthday theme from that
movie
topaz stands behind him just lightly
bobbing her hand and then of course thor
does the most dance move nebula shows up
at the crafts table getting korg to blow
on her dice mama needs a brand new eye
referring to the one thanos probably
pulled out of her after she lost a
sparring match to her sister drax and
valkyrie join lady siff at the bar thori
and jane get matching tattoos she gets a
mjolnir magic one he gets a microscope
science one a reference to his line in
the movie your ancestors called it magic
and you call it science
well i come from a place where they're
one in the same thing but i love how
while jane's skin is still pink and raw
and irritated thor's toughest nail skin
is already healed from the needle though
as an asgardian the needle should be
able to puncture his skin so maybe it's
just a decal and by the way if you
stream or podcast or if you want to
start doing that the hyperx quadcast is
the ideal standalone microphone for you
the quadcast comes with anti-vibration
shock mount to reduce the rumbles of
daily life and a built-in pop filter to
muffle pesky plosives the led indicator
lets you know your mic status if it's
lit it's live you can also tap to mute
to avoid those awkward broadcasting
moments like when someone is about to
yell if it's lit it's live it's got four
selectable polar patterns which allow
you to switch from settings suited to
streaming or music or an interview
instantaneously it's got a convenient
gain control dial to quickly adjust your
mic input sensitivity the quadcast s
model has cool rgb lighting and dynamic
effects that are customizable through
hyperx ingenuity software it's super
easy to use and a great looking mic that
also really ups your work zoom game the
quadcast family is compatible with pc
ps5 ps4 and mac as well as major
streaming platforms like obs studio and
xsplit so you will sound great to anyone
tuning in so head to hyperx dot gg new
rockstars or use the link in this
video's description to grab yourself a
hyperx quadcast might and start sounding
and looking better they wake up hungover
like the scene in the hangover there's
wild animals in the hotel room bandra
snugging with some possums and rocket
sleeps in the sink but remember rocket
is a character voiced by bradley cooper
who also woke up similar to this in that
hangover scene in the mirror behind
rocket someone wrote v was here maybe
for valkyrie who was seen partying with
them in this episode but it might also
be volstag and those hearts could have
been drawn by lady siff because they
wake up next to each other maybe they
hooked up as an infinity war thor thinks
rocket is a rabbit guys guys look
there's a cute little rabbit in the sink
rabbit is correct and clearly the
smartest among you rabbit brock rumlow
comes in with maria hill now acting
director of shield since fury got
incapacitated hey
this might be your party but this isn't
your planet before someone gets hurt i
need volcanoes
yes spickoli is sean penn's character
from fast times of richmond high another
nickname after like tony stark is called
thor point break and lebowski hill's
helicarrier hovers over vegas and is
numbered 67 furies helicarian avengers
was numbered 64. and coulson returns the
party atmosphere seems to be spreading
canada mongolia even pennsylvania dutch
country based on those mongolians we met
in loki these folks must love to party
hill uses nick fury's last resort
captain marvel pager from infinity war
and captain marvel then in paris thor
takes a selfie with some sovereigns
including their leader aisha loki
appears where's that son of a witch for
odin's son yes now a huge jacked frost
giant like his father lauphy and he has
a big horned crown of ice again it is
interesting to see him grow like this
when he's supposed to be the runt but i
suppose it was just odin's asgardian
magic that caused loki to take on those
human flesh tones in his size and of
course he calls thor son of a witch
because frigga is a witch as captain
marvel arrives france is just labeled in
big letters on the continent you can see
belgium in the netherlands beyond it's
just a really silly animation choice
that they use throughout the fight
something that you would see in looney
tunes carol calls him white snake like
the 80s hair band and thor responds his
name is four with a t and an r and an o
and an h not in that order yeah it
sounds right to me because tro in this
episode is very much a bro the words
off-screen height man returns there's a
mid-guardian word for women like you
[Music]
party
pooper there i said it captain marvel
dodges mjolnir but it hammerings back to
hitter in the back of the head later in
the fight carol learns to dodge it as it
comes from behind making her more like
that badass she wasn't end game when
thor summoned stormbreaker past her head
thor dickishly domino's stonehenge eric
selvig's favorite place to streak
similar to how clark griswold does this
in european vacation they slug it out
it's awesome to watch carol beams his
head and he levitates mjolnir from one
hand to the other in order to break her
hold and all this while some great
electronic rock music plays
evoking a music composed for ragnarok by
mark mother's ball thor anchors her with
mjolnir and the other partiers include a
guy dressed in a celestial inspired
costume like those we saw in sakaar oh
wrinkle mouth on the right is one of
those sakar gladiators as well as that
weird helmet dude on the left and then
yeah a few skrulls point in mock carol
as the pooper kind of cold considering
she saved a lot of their fellow refugees
16 years earlier maria hill references
carol's flirting goose your cat could
devour whole armies you've got a cat
what's his name goose oh top gun you're
maverick is your ego writing checks that
your skills can't cash no calling back
the line from top gun son your ego is
writing checks your body can't cash and
she says that she thought carol would be
a dude captain referencing the fact that
captain marvel was a male superhero
originally they discussed hitting thor
with a nuke level blast it's not a bad
idea actually the mojave desert could
withstand the hit the mojave desert is
where shield built project pegasus which
in avengers the tesseract portal caused
to implode in a huge crater just shows
how they designed the space in case
something like that might happen sirter
clancy brown returned to voice him
flirts with the statue of liberty burns
her arm off and then the frost giants
deface mount rushmore using the casket
of ancient winters the party moves on to
the sydney harbour bridge where korg
dances with a baby pacifier alongside
some more familiar faces mantis sebas
guardian soldiers one of those yellow
sex spots from contraxia more scrolls
ravagers and sovereign valkyrie and meek
shows up and then that strainer helmet
dude is another runaway gladiator from
sakar jane contacts heindall and finds
frigga filling her in but only between
sips of chardonnay it's thor
he's in trouble he's on earth carol
knocks thor to siberia where hill and
rumlow prep to nuke them both but forget
intervenes what are you doing here you
must be using a lot of dark magic just
to check in on me yeah dark magic or
dark energy is what the asgardians use
to transport themselves without the
bifrost as loki mentioned avengers with
the bifrost gone how much dark energy
did the your father have to muster to
conjure you here and as heimdall said in
his dying breath
[Music]
loki apparently played to use the st
louis arch as a giant slingshot and then
to the left of yondu with the mask
that's another sakar gladiator from
ragnarok they got all those guys in
there it's pretty cool but everyone
bounces let's go topaz we shall ride
like the real please lose it right hand
we're keeping the scoot scoops nebula
refers to thanos um i think i hear my
dad calling good luck but thor uses
millionaire to scare everyone into
helping him out you can see the disc on
the top shows the same norse runes on
mjolnir from the films and these
translate to he who wields this hammer
commands the lightning and the storm
they pick stonehenge and the st louis
arch the power blackout the statue of
liberty mount rushmore and the ferris
wheel and even though it wasn't their
fault the leaning tower of pisa it's
actually kind of similar to how evil
superman fixes this when he doesn't need
to in superman three thor also scrubs
thor rocks off of a wall and judging
from the white house behind him this
must be the washington monument so thor
tries to fool friga but mjolnir is
covered in underwear and mardi gras
beads and graffiti looks like it reads
crazy night and drifting and hot tea and
then there's a picture of someone
bearded this might be thor from another
time when he had that awesome beard thor
schedules a date with jane and the
watcher tries to wrap things up together
they lived happily ever after
but he blinks i know it's just a
character blinking but it does cause the
gleam of his eyes to vanish briefly i
just think it's another example of how
this watcher's more human features make
him less of an eternally seeing godly
presence because if one can blink one
can miss things even for the briefest
moments which might be why as he
realizes this is actually twist ending
he says wait what
huh yeah normally the watcher is the one
to tell us when a dark ending is coming
but this time he is caught off guard as
much as we are i think this sets up the
watcher to finally intervene on a
multiversal threat that he worries might
even affect his own existence that
threat an army of ultron sentries coming
from a portal led by ultravision armed
with all six infinity stones but since
the mind stone is in vision's head it is
the green time stone that is in his
chest the time stone being the
penultimate stone that thanos got before
the mine stone i love how all of these
sentries are eliminated red which in age
of ultron was how we could tell which
one drone contained ultron's
consciousness at any given moment but
this tells us that this ultron can exist
as all of them simultaneously of course
using his stones this ultron must have
completed his original plan to transfer
his consciousness into the synthozoid
body with vibranium infused tissue and
the mind stone which of course the
avengers converted into vision using
jarvis ai but in this universe tony
stark would not yet have the mind stone
in order to launch his ultron ai and
create that problem to begin with so
this ultravision must come from another
universe one where he might have used
that divine knowledge from the mind
stone to locate all the other stones
before thanos could and then went on to
conquer that reality and then move from
reality to reality to conquer the
multiverse but this also means we are
learning a new function of the six
infinity stones combined not just the
ability to erase half of all life or all
of life but the ability to transcend
realities as a nexus being which also
poses some terrifying implications for
zombie thanos who also acquired all six
stones we know from trailer footage that
party thor will join a team of black
widow captain carter strange supreme and
others as they fight ultron centuries
and there was a clip of party thor
telling strange zombies great idea
making me wonder if the watcher's next
move will be to assemble these misfit
toys into a team to play these two nexus
threats to the multiverse ones that he
did not see coming until now against
each other you can support new rockstars
by checking out our great merch options
at newrockstarsmerch.com like this
awesome what if shirt get one of these
you can write in a custom shout out for
our what if after show follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you